there's a new era and I'm not part of it
and that's kind of how I that's a little
bit how I feel when I see this and I
don't how do you feel when you see this
and how do you intend to kind of like
Get Your Hands you know we're a bunch of
scheming greedy you know so we're good
people how are you gonna get your hands
on this how are you gonna get your your
stick and paws in this game
[Music]
okay this is the AI episode
it's all AI everything is AI
um
I was mind blown I would say that's the
right word like to me this is the
biggest holy [__] moment I've had when
it's come to when it comes to technology
of seeing what's going on in AI
um for you you got emotional which is so
strong I think I I think I'm more
emotional than you are I think I like I
get touched more than you do
uh let me give the background really
quick so it's a company called play.ht
um but and one of their side projects is
a thing called podcast.ai and basically
what they did was
they gave their AI algorithm or program
whatever you want to call it they gave
their program uh Steve Jobs's biography
uh which is and I think they actually
gave him one or two of his biographies
because there's two or two major ones
then they basically gave they gave the
program every single Steve Jobs
recording I think ever or any of that
they could find on the internet along
with every Joe Rogan episode ever and
they made Joe Rogan interview Steve Jobs
and in the interview it's like 25
minutes long they talk all about all
types of stuff but they say some amazing
things like Joe Rogan does the intro and
he goes like he teases out the who who
it is just like he does in real life he
goes what's up freak [__] which I
don't even think he says anymore but he
said that in all the early episodes he
goes what's up freak [__] uh today's
guest is someone who's incredibly smart
incredibly we should just play it right
let it let it insufferable well he says
insufferable which I thought was crazy
so go ahead this podcast is broke
brought to you by play dot HT
all content is generated by artificial
choice for this part listener discretion
is advised
hello freak [__] welcome to another
episode of the Bro joke and experience
and on this episode I welcome my friend
who's difficult to describe I'm
fascinated by him and I hope you'll be
too and he is weird and Brilliant and
sometimes totally insufferable but my
guest today has made some of the great
technological products of our age and
he's always pushing the envelope in
Innovation like for example with his
next computer he developed a new
programming language and operating
system and then he became even more
famous for making three applications for
that computer uh word processor
spreadsheet and an image editor that
just showed me that this dude was
brilliant had amazing taste and I would
just hope that I could be even like one
tenth of the genius that my friend today
is and I can't even say his name so yeah
so super psyched about having him in the
house today first time or yeah we've had
you on before but not for a long time
like Patrick Swayze and um Demi Moore
and ghost you're a memory from the past
[Laughter]
so without further Ado my friend who is
difficult to describe and wonderful and
I'm so grateful he came on the show
how's it going good to see you buddy
it's been a long time since I've been on
the show I've missed this it's always
fun wow like just pause there okay
so the things that like first the voice
quality the voice quality is incredible
like that sounds just like Joe Rogan it
sounds just like Steve Jobs it is it has
gotten so much better than like how this
used to be I remember like you know when
you had like the Garmin GPS in your car
and you could like choose the Morgan
Freeman Voice or whatever like any time
you'd have like this voice robot that I
was trying to say something new it
sounded totally computerized and this
doesn't so the voice quality is one
thing the fact that it kind of like
it makes more sense it makes more sense
than it should like he's doing an intro
it understands that he's teasing like
this my friend who's here today this
person's a genius but not saying who it
is and what it is right away that's like
a Showmanship thing that I thought was
like really interesting
um the back and forth banter like he
gives that long intro and then Steve
Jobs just kind of laughs
um like you would if you had sat down
for this kind of interview with Joe
Rogan I just thought that was incredible
the way it felt like a real conversation
and obviously there's some stuff that's
like
you know he's talking about word
processors and documents and a little
too much like nobody would do that but
like
damn if 80 of that is not amazing and
the reason I felt emotional listening to
this was it's I felt both like in awe
but also scared because as I was
listening to this it I was agreeing with
what Steve says and uh what we'll do in
a second uh Ben is fast forward like
maybe 10 minutes in and basically jobs
goes on this long rant about LSD saying
it was uh you know LSD changed my life
and I don't think it's for everyone but
it changed my life and it opened my mind
up and let me read all these books I
never previously would have read and he
says something like I don't I wouldn't
take LSD a bunch of times in a row
because I only needed it once or twice
and it opened my mind and it introduced
me and he goes in depth he goes it
introduced me to India and it's just he
talks about he's talking about God he's
talking about like all kinds of things
that you're like
it's not just like reading a Wikipedia
page you know what I mean like uh it's
very philosophical he's like when people
think about God they think about this
but to me it's and it's like well that's
a fully formed thought and philosophy
and like that sounds like something
somebody would say when they're having
like an in-depth podcast and not just
like I did this in 1979 in March when I
was living in Albuquerque and then in
1981 I once again it was wasn't that it
was like a very real sounding thing and
he has this amazing did you hear there's
this beautiful quote that he says and
basically the way that this company if
you ever listen to a bunch of Steve Jobs
interviews you'll notice that at points
it almost sounds like they're just
chopping up some of his clips and just
weaving them together because he has
talked about this before so I don't
actually know if he's ever said this
particular line before but he starts
talking about India and why he loves
like uh that part of the world and he
basically says like well it's so old and
it influenced the rest of society and he
goes there's an Indian epic that's ten
times as long as the Bible the Quran and
all these other things
Odyssey yeah that's what he says yeah
he's like basically Indian history
influence the rest of the world and
there's an epic that's ten times as long
as all these other books and I just
thought that that's just like such an
interesting thing he does so he doesn't
say the name so it kind of leaves you
wanting there but he is talking about
the the Gita which is like is I think
that long it's like a 16 part
series or whatever it's like this really
really long thing I would bet that it
actually is multiples longer than the
Iliad and the Odyssey so I I feel so
interesting that he said that and this
is the point is that when he said that I
said I gotta find that book like he just
sold me on this book he influenced you
yeah the dead jobs influenced me so Ben
click play just for like 30 seconds but
there is some kind of deeper meaning to
life and it can't just be something that
somebody made up because if it was it
wouldn't be compelling it would seem
contrived and everyone would see through
it so I think that the meaning and the
purpose is by the cosmos the nature of
the cosmos which is pretty bold thinking
I mean I don't know how else to put it
but it's not religious in the way people
usually talk about
taking LSD was a profound experience for
me LSD shows you that there's another
side to the coin and you can't remember
it when it wears off but you know it it
washes over you and tells you that
everything is connected you're not here
by accident you were put here for a
purpose and if you can figure out what
that is then you'll learn more about
yourself than anything else could it's
pretty intense so so that quote is a
real quote of his technology was a
profound experience one of the most
important things of my life it shows you
that there's another side of the coin
you can't remember it when it wears off
but you know it okay so that is like an
actual quote of his but it's weaved into
the conversation like there's a part in
the conversation where he where he says
he's talking about how he's a fan of Joe
Rogan he's like it's nice to just sit
back in the car and listen to you rant
and it's like okay so the first one
where he's the the LSD you know okay he
they just took a they just took you know
his Goodreads section or his quotes and
they're like okay cool he's he says
things like this
but where did how did it know to say to
Joe Rogan that I love to listen to your
podcast and the car just love to sit
back and listen to your rant where would
that have come from how how does that
happen that is there's like little
moments like that that are like
I just don't understand this technology
well enough to know how it could know to
say something like that in that moment
so the first half of the call he talks
all about India and these like kind of
platitude like life advice type of
things which were pretty amazing but
then the second half which bends just
started playing a little bit this he
talks about Google and they actually say
Yahoo Ron they call it yahoo uh they put
the emphasis on the wrong syllable but
they uh he's he like does all these like
says all these interesting quotes which
I actually think are things that he said
again in the past but he says stuff like
you know that's the problem I've always
had with Microsoft in many ways they're
smart people and they've done good work
but they've never had any tastes they've
never had any aesthetic taste and then
he goes on and he talks about Adobe and
he criticizes adobe's business model and
he goes uh Joe Rogan actually says what
would you do to fix Adobe and job says
well they've got 800 people working on
adobe's business model that's just way
too many people and the fact that they
charge just a little bit of money for a
small bits of the product it's like
buying a car but only getting part of
the car and having to pay more money to
get the rest of the engine and he like
says these criticisms about Adobe which
frankly have no idea if it's true but it
must have went on like a rant about this
you know in the past but and and then he
goes you know I had a lunch recently
with Bob whatever at Adobe and he like
says their full name and he leads up
this part of adobe and he actually
agreed to me that they need to fix it
and they're working on fixing it and so
anyway he like actually gives
almost more advice and his opinions on
what I think are current events I'm not
well versed enough with Adobe but it
seems like current events it's pretty
magical
it's amazing yeah this basically was
like bring bring back someone from the
dead technology band do you have
anything to add your uh you're a history
guy what did this like do you have
anything that you felt when you when you
watched this
I really agree with Sam it made me oddly
emotional uh listening to it it also
scared me a little bit just because I
thought of the application of like what
if like you did this to my grandpa and
like what emotions would that bring back
and then that like frightened me of like
oh I don't know if that's a good thing
to be able to experience like
there's a representation my grandpa that
would feel like the real thing but isn't
right like where are these thoughts
coming from so it's equal parts like
really compelling really cool as like a
treat to be able to hear
well I think it's like a pretty accurate
representation of how Steve Jobs would
approach some of these things that are
happening today but then also just like
scary to realize but it's not really him
and what is it really well so let me
it's like a video right today you could
watch a home video and it's like you see
their face you hear their voice it's
captured a moment in time to me this is
an extension of that which is like now
it's gonna be somewhat interactive that
you can kind of interact with these
people or hear them talk about new
things uh and you know that it's not
like the real thing but it's you know
there's a black mirror episode that's a
lot like this where the the woman like
uploads her boyfriend's Consciousness to
like you know this robot she's kind of
still dating him even though uh you know
he's gone but like there's like the
shadow of him that like you know can can
simulate him
um and I think I think there's more good
than bad
um Sam what do you want to say yeah so
let me add two points about why this is
gonna give it even stranger well the
first point is is is almost scary so
basically in 1985 here this is a quote
from Steve Jobs he goes my hope is
someday when the next Aristotle is alive
we can capture the underlying world view
of that Aristotle in a computer and
someday some student will not be only be
able to read the words Aristotle wrote
but ask Aristotle a question and get an
answer and so Steve Jobs wrote that in
85 5 which is interesting now here's
where things get really interesting from
that because that's that's he is what
he's what just happened what he just
described is what just happened to him
it's magical now here's where things are
going to get even more magical so play
dot is it play dot AI or play dot HD uh
so uh part of their website you can
actually vote for new episodes and some
of the top episodes that people have
voted for is Elon Musk interviewing uh
Nikola Tesla Kanye West and Bob Marley
talking about music Jesus interviews God
and then I believe there's Einstein and
Buddha having a conversation on science
and spirituality
um Trump interviews himself Trump
interviews himself there's Lex Friedman
interviewing Richard Feynman and then
there's uh Joe Rogan mediates peace
between Russia and U.S and that sounds
like a joke and it is a joke but it's
actually an interesting tool yeah where
you're like well like let's hear Joe
Rogan let's see if Joe Rogan can like
bring together these two people
different people and hear each other's
perspective and we'll actually find out
where one another's coming from even if
it's make-believe and but it will still
be like maybe that is actually how they
feel and I could work through this
argument so that's why this stuff is
actually really really interesting and
Powerful
so let's switch gears I want to give you
my kind of like big picture
framework on how I think about AI so
um I was having lunch
with this guy who has built this AI app
uh he built one app called I think Wombo
is the name of it had like 100 million
downloads it basically could take a
picture of you and make you like make it
look like you're singing uh and then
they got copied a bunch and got taken
out of the app store because of Music
problems and then like I saw that uh now
he has another one which is basically
like one of these um
text to Image Creators on mobile and
it's like really popular
and he started saying this thing and I
kind of remixed what he was saying and
here's kind of like how here's where we
landed with like what's going on with AI
so the last I don't know 10 years have
been what I'll call left brain AI
and like you know you have your left
brain and your right brain left brain
left brain is your analytical brain
and that's what artificial intelligence
could do you had big data you had
machine learning you had you know oh the
computer can play chess and it's amazing
the computer can play go and it's
amazing it beats the best players in the
world you had self-driving cars where a
car is taking in sensor data camera data
and it's basically processing it and
trying to make decisions like a human
being using analytical decision-making
processes it's trying to make the right
Judgment at the right time to maximize
safety and so that's what I think that's
where we've been and it's also in a way
what we expected that sounds like the
type of thing that super computer should
be able to do is like hey computer you
know just like you can multiply huge
numbers and I can't do that in my head
you know you should be able to drive
perfectly every time you should be able
to play chess better than a human like
great I get that stuff
and then was this game changer where it
changed into right brain AI your right
brain is your creative brain
right so this is where you got gpt3
which is what generates
um text like you know what we just
talked about with the Joe Rogan thing so
you can just give it a prompt and it'll
just write an essay for you it'll be
creative it can write rap lyrics for you
and that's where you got Dali which is
Art so you could just say give me a
picture of a starry night but with uh
takes place in Hogwarts and it'll just
generate images that like create that's
you know paint pictures for you and so
you know all of a sudden the artists are
looking at this saying wait a minute
wait a minute it was fine when you were
just messing with chess but now now
you're holding the paintbrush what's
going on here and then you have that you
know what we just played you know um
play HT or unreal speech they're doing
this for audio like how do you generate
audio whether that's music whether
that's uh podcast it's just creating it
from scratch and you know like here's
podcasters like us that's wake up and we
sit at our microphone and we have to
come up with this content but now the
machines are doing it too and um and so
we're competing with that and then you
have people doing this with video
there's a company called Runway that's
doing this where you can just describe a
video like walking through the streets
of Tokyo and it's really busy and then
it creates that scene and they go can
you add some rain and then it adds rain
what what's that called Runway ml
okay right now and just use it Ben pull
up the demo for Runway ml um I don't
know if it's like launched yet but they
they put out a sick demo of what I just
described and so now you got this right
brain AI That's doing creative [__]
Creative Images creative texts creative
videos it's writing blog posts it's
writing essays it's making paintings
it's making patterns it's making music
it's making podcasts it's making videos
and so now it's doing both sides and
that's the big change that's happened
and that's the big holy [__] moment in
the same way that nfts brought a whole
bunch of people into crypto who you know
crypto when it was just cryptography or
it was just Finance
um there was certain set of people that
were interested then nfts came out and
it was like oh cool there's a whole art
angled you know like celebrity access it
brought a new audience in this is that
on steroids where the new AI stuff
that's creative and is creating art and
creating music and creating audio and
creating text that's bringing in a whole
new wave of people Beyond just people
who are interested in a chess spot or a
alpha you know at the alpha zero bot
that plays plays go
um you know those were kind of limited
to like just the Nerds and now we got
the Nerds and the artists both in the
mix that's my framework for what's going
on with AI and the next 10 years I think
are this like right brain side taken
over and this is that is that it what is
that yeah so let's see oh my God like
it's like make it feel more romantic at
a uh remove the you just highlight an
object it's like remove this I don't
want this in the video and it just
removes the Street Lamp and then it's
like make a lush Garden make it look
like it is hand drawn make it look like
a a jungle where there's whatever going
on
[Music]
wow
so like like that last thing it just did
is so crazy it just you dropped a video
in and it goes green screen the
character and it's a guy walking around
and it just like immediately removes the
background and then it says add a sunny
sky and they add to Sunny Sky then it
says blur the Sun a little bit blur the
background a little bit and it blurs the
background while this guy's like
skateboarding or whatever like that's
crazy that it could do that
um you know and now obviously you know a
demo is generally like massive over
promise for what the tech can actually
do yeah but it's but we can all see it
we can all see that like if they're not
doing it now like it it's reasonable
that in the in the near term of 10 years
like this is gonna be normal and there's
two inches to that guy's neck beard and
this is done like yeah
yeah
we're measuring timelines by uh by
parallel hair growth they um
this is one of those things and it
doesn't happen often where you see
something and you say to yourself it's
not there yet but it will be and it's
almost like where you like test it's
almost like when I was in a Tesla for
the first time and it went and it was
like a practical car that also went zero
to 60 in three seconds even though the
range wasn't good and like this other
thing wasn't good but I get into it I'm
like oh well yeah like in 10 years this
is what this is just the norm this will
be normal and those types it's like
puberty it's like there's a bunch of
changes happening the voice is changing
but it still cracks and you're like oh
it doesn't sound great yet but it'll get
there yeah and this is one of those
things and and it's pretty magical when
you see it and like a really some
seemingly basic but actually quite
profound uh ways that this is going to
impact thing I mean it's basically it's
almost like I don't know if you know
anything about music but like I was
listening to this documentary on uh
Nirvana and Dave Grohl was talking about
his newest album he's going to use
analog like which is like tape recording
he's gonna like record it like with the
all in one room but because he's like
with Pro Tools like you know it's the
technology it's the Recording Technology
they use it's called Pro Tools it's kind
of like Photoshop but for music and he
was like we could record all this music
and like we only got to do it one time
and then we can like drag and drop
different stuff and we make like the
sound perfect like the every snare is
like exactly on the beat that it should
be and it's perfect and he's like we
kind of wanted it to be a little
sloppier to feel more human because Pro
Tools has made this stuff perfect and
that's an example of what's going to
happen and like some really mundane but
interesting examples are basically you
know have you ever done like
sale like high ticket sales are you
trying to sell software or some type of
service that requires tons of back and
forth on email a view like called
emailing someone and then like them
saying like oh well this is kind of
interesting but we need this this and
this and then you have to like reply
back sure that costs so much money worth
the people you got to train people on
the right things to say you've got to
give them documentation on all the right
things to say then you gotta like add in
like the wow factor of like can you like
flirt with them the right way and can
you like play this game the right way
like that [__] like reasonably it's it's
reasonable to see that that will all be
automated in in the near term like a
call center won't be a thing there's
gonna be like your AI call center or
whatever we want to call that your
operations Hub and then there's going to
be like just in case that doesn't work
we'll have a couple people there right
well I uh one of the companies I invest
in is called Infinitis and the the funny
thing that they did was they're like oh
man doctors spend so much time their
back office like just trying to do
billing with insurance so that you'll
call up basically you know patient gives
you information for insurance you then
have to call the insurance company you
have to verify the name and the number
and you have to get it like here's the
reference code for what treatment they
had or whatever right all this back and
forth and
um most entrepreneurs solution was like
oh this is so much back and forth we
need to eliminate this and re-change the
system from scratch and what these guys
did was way smarter they were like oh
why don't we just save the doctors a ton
of time let's make a robot that calls
their robot and so they created a robot
that will call you know whoever
insurance providers robot and the
insurance provider is like please enter
here the patient's identification number
and then the robot goes nine two four
three three six it's like thank you for
your patience robot and it's like please
say if you want number one and then the
robot has infinite patience to just do
the whole call by itself and it saves
doctors a ton of time they're doing
really really well let me give you
um we have to talk about interior AI
yeah so let's do a couple other examples
so uh here's another one where you know
Peter levels who came on the Pod
um you know massive at a fan favorite
this guy's got like a killer following
and one of the reasons why is because
he loves to just hack together and make
stuff I think when you I think when you
were looking at his thing you called him
and what did you call him you called him
an artist in that way too you're like
yeah I got your description of them but
you're like you're a um
I can't remember it was something like
you called him basically like a like a a
code artist or something like that well
I I don't know remember what I call them
but to me he's like a Craftsman you know
like he's like a he's like a punk rocker
who like uh he's like a musician who
just instead of playing on a a musical
keyboard he's playing on the computer
keyboard and he's pretty magical he's a
pretty magical like Creator I think yeah
there's definitely an element of punk to
him where he's like for example he's
like I don't do email or phone calls
ever if you wanna if you have a question
for me here's a frequently Asked
question thing like why because I like
to just work on my [__] and then I like
to go swimming and like those are the
things I want to do right he's like you
know I don't want to live in one place
I'm gonna just move around and like be a
nomad and I think that's cool he did
that before remote work was popular so
explain what this is he's been building
it publicly on Twitter for a while now
for about three or four months maybe so
uh no not even dude like a couple weeks
so
um he created this thing it's interior
AI like interior design and what you do
is you could basically upload a photo of
any space
and you say what it is you say you drop
it you drag and drop a photo of a face
by the way I want to create a YouTube
video that does all these demos live one
by one
um but like you upload a space and then
you say what type of room it is you say
what type of style you want like do you
want
ski chalet do you want tropical do you
want like minimalist do you want a
maximalist look and then you um you say
how many versions you want and then you
click render my idea and it just creates
like an interior designer would a super
realistic like go to his Twitter and
just look at the um look at his like
demos there Ben
um it generates like a super realistic
looking interior so he took like for
example
um Kim Kardashian's house and he took
the photo from their like living room
and then he uploaded
um
he said like you know give me a give me
some inspiration and it turned it into
like a hot spring like it turned it into
like a whole different like thing and it
all together
um but it's really amazing and it's like
yeah here's all the stuff you would need
to make your house look like this do you
like this look nope you want a new one
push a button get another one push a
button get another one push another
which is what you were saying that would
be so much back and forth with a human
being you can sit down for design
meetings and then they would have create
a look book and then you'd give your
feedback and then they would you know
maybe give you a rendering but that
takes time and energy on their part and
then you'd say no and then you'd have to
go back and forth here you just push
buttons and you just immediately get
this like dream it's like you just get
to Dream Out Loud and like you're just
dreaming and it's just generating images
of like you know that for you to kind of
like remix off of which is a totally
different creative process like that
cuts so much friction out of the
creative process that even somebody like
me who doesn't have design taste this is
a the superpower to give you design
taste but B it takes all the friction
out so you don't have the impatience
right okay look at that look at this one
yeah go back and forth to this so so
it's this crappy Warehouse like space
just empty I don't know Sam like
describe what you're like it's so this
is clearly an old factory that someone's
trying to turn into an apartment so it's
an industrial style thousand to two
thousand square foot room that looks
beautiful but is too rustic to live in
and entirely empty and he says uh I
found an original empty loft photo I
wanted to add interior decorating that
was industrial style and I wanted to
Auto detect different parts around the
building so it looks like there's like a
pillar in the in the middle of the room
so he wanted he said I wanted to
decorate around that and he said all
right go ahead interior AI do it and
let's look at the next picture
and then it turns it into this like
modern looking Loft uh it's the same
place
um and then it replaces the floor and
then it does this and it does that like
and you could I think there's another
version that it creates like it creates
like multiple versions of it
um oh my gosh
yes this one's crazy right they have
like replace the roof with like bamboo
and like you could see through the roof
now so you know some of this is not
super realistic but you said something
earlier that I think is worth noting
which is
um it's not perfect and there's like
definitely some weird stuff that it's
like well that doesn't make any sense
but
you have to see through that right now
because that stuff's gonna get better
and there's this great blog post from
back in the day by this guy Paul bukite
who created Gmail when he was inside
Google and then the blog post is called
if you're great you don't have to be
good
which honestly is kind of the motto of
my life right like Sam do I show up late
to this podcast yeah I do
am I wearing my boxers right now yeah I
am did I prepare for this podcast not
fully but if you're great you don't have
to be good and like that's true he's
like you know with Gmail people were
like oh my God it doesn't have this and
it doesn't have a contact book and it
doesn't have this he's like yeah but
look it's lightning fast has unlimited
storage and the search is amazing you
can find any file in any email instantly
and he's like when you're great you
don't have to be good he's like the iPad
people were like oh my God it doesn't
have a keyboard it doesn't have a USB
port it doesn't have this it doesn't
have that he's like yeah but watch this
you Tap a button and it like instantly
is on it doesn't have like a boot up
process and like you swipe and you're on
the internet and it just lets you browse
the internet from your like your couch
you know where you're you're you know on
the go where you're you don't have your
laptop or you don't have your desktop
computer he's like so when you're great
you don't have to be good and he had
released that when the iPad came out
he's like look the iPad just got
released all these critics are saying
how that's a huge flop I think they're
wrong because they're making this
mistake they want things to be good
everywhere but you just need to be great
in like three things that matter and
everything else can be kind of sucky and
it'll still win and he was absolutely
right about the iPad
are you so let's talk about opinions a
little bit where's your head at with all
this I mean when I see this I think a I
am not capable like I I don't have the
ability to work on this I I just I
simply don't have the horsepower and
like I appreciate it but I the engine I
got upstairs only yeah it's more of a
go-kart okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm definitely well I'm like I I'm very
much either gonna be a spectator or a
only semi active person in this in this
game like you know you made a You made a
funny joke when we were talking you and
I so Sean and I are obsessed with Tick
Tock so we watch Tick Tock constantly
and we made a joke or Sean made a joke
he goes we're content creators in the
same way that uh a horse carriage person
uh in 1912 and they just saw Henry Ford
Drive by on his car yeah
you're like oh [__]
yeah I see an 18 year old with Vans who
like makes this like spectacular like
video of uh and it's just the funniest
thing ever and I'm like oh there there's
a new era and I'm not part of it right
and that's kind of how I that's a little
bit how I feel when I see this and I
don't how do you feel when you see this
and how do you intend to kind of like
Get Your Hands you know wear a bunch of
scheming greedy you know people how are
you gonna get your hands on this how are
you gonna get your your stinking paws in
this game well that's a great question
it's a question I've been asking myself
I'm a little bit different than you and
that I'm I give my I have a little more
self-delusion where I'm like I could do
this you know um I could I I if I hired
the right people you know I could be the
vision guy yeah yeah I'll be the vision
guy and like you know I'll have the idea
and then all these Geniuses will just
make it because you you you previously
had a company that was a a my I would
tell my parents I had a tech company but
it was really just an email newsletter
it wasn't a tech company you actually
had a proper technology business right
right yeah you you were just basically
like writing brochures and uh whereas I
was running a Silicon Valley yeah yeah
Enterprise I'm like I'm like uh uh a
restaurant who has an online ordering
menu uh calling themselves a tech
company
the next Google
um yeah yeah I'm used to working with
people that are way smarter than me and
I like go over to I rolled my chair over
to their screen and they're just like
what do you want I'm like hey bud
um can you do that thing again where you
made the thing like bounce during the
animation like that was so cool I want
to just like upload this to my Twitter
can you do it again and they're like oh
yeah sure
um so I'm used to working with designers
engineers at waytown today so I I kind
of look at it as following my plan is
this invest in everything because
investing is easy and great uh right
like I'm a believer in this wave I'm
excited about this and I think that I
can help because a lot of the people who
can build this stuff they don't know a
where to apply it like what's the what's
the actual pain point I should be
solving and B they don't know how to
like build maybe a defensible business
or a go to market strategy that might
make sense for them so I'm like okay
cool I'm gonna invest in a bunch of
these companies that's plan a that's
already in motion would you say that
this is the most interesting sector
um for sure for sure and I kind of feel
like an idiot because it's like oh cool
now you're interested in the new thing
and it's like
on one hand I get that
um you know
oh crypto you are you are in fact uh a
dumb idiot who chases yeah I just chased
the next shiny object and there's some
truth to that like crypto was the more
crypto prices went up the more I
invested and the more uh you know then I
created the milk Road and like that you
know I turned my content attention to it
um so you know now oh you know it's like
that Meme it's like you know the guy the
guy who looks back at the new the new
thing that's like you know the hot thing
behind it it's like yeah AI is that new
thing
but at the same time what am I supposed
to do I just saw a [__] flying object
I just saw a UFO what am I supposed to
do pretend I'm not interested like no
I'm super interested like you know Count
Me In Like beat me up and you know have
your way with me aliens that's how I
feel about AI
did I ever tell you the time that in our
office there was a porn Studio across
the street that would leave their
windows open
so
so at my office in San Francisco was at
Bush and Kearney in the financial
district of San Francisco and we were on
maybe the fifth floor and there used to
be this company called breather and it
was almost like Airbnb but for office
space maybe like wework uh where they
would like pre-rent tons of like one
single small rooms a meeting room yeah
yeah a meeting room and then you could
rent it by the hour and we had these
huge beautiful windows at our office and
you could see across the street which
was only
20 yards you know just the size of a
small Street and you can see across
where this other room was and eventually
this soft core porn company started
renting it uh it was a breather and they
would rent it by the hour and I think it
was for only fans I think it was where a
freelance photographer who specialized
in like webcam girls or something like
that and they would come and take like
their their portfolio pictures and they
would always comment like two days a
week at like two o'clock and they would
get completely naked and they would just
be there taking pictures and I had this
woman working for me named Edie who's
probably 65. and heard I sat next to
each other and I remember like it
happened and be like uh yeah they're
there again today and like you can't not
look at Edie's like hardcore Catholic
and she used to like they're here yeah
she would do like the side of the Cross
and like start holding onto her like
Rosary or whatever they would come in
and she was like oh she like she would
say like oh baby Jesus like you know
dear
she was more so I'm like wow I was like
wow
and uh it was one of those things where
I remember sitting there and our office
was like six young men and then like
Edie and this this this like porn was
just not not porn but this nude photo
photography was just happening right
there and we just like had to stare at
it all day and I remember it being so
challenging to work when that was
happening that's sort of like AI That's
my long tangent yeah I was like where is
he going with this okay yeah I'm with
you I'm with you on that that's that is
you don't remember that you were never
there when the the they got naked no
I've never saw that
um but you know thanks for not inviting
me
um so so yeah that that is how I feel
about this where I'm like what am I
supposed to do not look Edie
um yeah I'm looking I'm looking and you
know I'm looking as long as they're
there that's how I feel about AI so I'm
gonna invest in this stuff uh I'm Gonna
Keep learning about it and then who
knows maybe start a company in this
space you know it's pretty exciting yeah
it's exciting I mean like this is like a
it is exciting it's an unlock it's like
oh we got new toys to play with like I
can't leave them in the box like I gotta
unbox it and see what I could do with it
so you know I I don't know we'll see
what happens with this but let me give
you a couple other
um kind of mind-blowing you know
examples here so okay so another one is
Jasper so I just invested in this
company called Jasper Jasper dude the
valuation was steep I'm shocked you did
it
yeah the revenue curve is also steep
it's working really well and now I I
went in and I told him this I go
your numbers are insane
um this might be fraud that's okay you
know we'll see I don't think it's prod
but like the numbers are so so
impressive that it's like you know when
you say wow that's unbelievable there's
a part of you that's like is it wait is
this believable
um so you know there's there's that I
said the other thing is you know
sometimes these companies that get off
to really hot starts they don't
necessarily sustain like uh sometimes
that explosive growth can can but it can
also break you Groupon you know during
covet hop-in was an example of this
where hoppin was like you know started
and it was like the perfect thing at the
perfect time and it just took off like a
rocket ship and it became worth five
billion dollars and then now there's
like they just laid off like whatever a
thousand people because
covet ended the demand went down they
couldn't sustain that sales growth they
had forecasted that that they'll always
keep growing like a rocket and maybe
that didn't happen so you know and by
the way the founder
took 100 million dollars in secondary
yeah you know just had to secure the bag
for his family right uh he's like I got
kids
he don't but
I'm gonna have kids I better get this
back I'm gonna use that excuse all the
time regardless of I got kids dude I got
kids to feed I got a family right
I am such a good uncle
um okay so check out this demo of what
Jasper can do so basically I teach like
a um a writing course called Power
writing and my whole goal is like hey if
you're gonna write something on your
website or an email or your Twitter bio
or you want to write content for blogs
like you're either gonna write it and No
One's Gonna read it it's gonna go
nowhere it's gonna drive no results no
clicks no signups no followers or it's
gonna like actually like achieve the
thing
so it's like a genie right you say you
say what you want and you just give it
like a little guidance like make it
funny I want an ad that's gonna like
promote my gym it's called crunch uh we
have this welcome offer where you get it
for 20 bucks make it funny and I want it
as a Facebook ad and then I want it as a
cold email and they just and you're like
give me 10 options and it gives you 10
options and then you can just like edit
them or whatever or you could literally
highlight it and just say rephrase this
I didn't like the way I didn't like this
intro give me a new one it'll just give
you a new one you're like give them
another one it's like gives you another
one I mean it's like the best employee
that's like creative super prompt just
immediately delivers the thing you want
it's kind of like amazing so like watch
watch like another 30 seconds this is
like the boss mode version access to
documents now I want you to imagine
documents it's kind of like Google Docs
if you had an assistant in there and
you're the boss getting your assistant
instructions on how to do stuff now for
our first example imagine a real estate
agent who has a lot of outbound sales
emails to send out this week and he
wants to save some time by using his AI
system Jasper now you're probably
getting a hang of this by now on the
left we give Jasper some context of our
situation any background information we
need along with tone of voice and
keywords and then on the right we can
supply a pattern so Jasper can follow
that because Jasper is really good at
following patterns and apply that with
all the information it knows from the
internet so here we just provided a
really good example of what good
behavior would look like and then we
provided some merge tags empty little
slots that we want Jasper to fill in in
our situation the real estate agents
Dave clients James markets Austin Texas
it's the New Year season the man is up
inventory is down and we want them to
hop on a call so now we're going to
write with AI we're going to do a Jasper
command remember that feature for later
okay now what we're gonna do is activate
voice mode
hey Jasper write an email from Dave to
James about an update on the Austin
Texas real estate market and ask for a
call later this week
all right we're submitting that command
imagine if you're the boss and Jasper is
your assistant now he's following your
directions
look at that it's perfect you go ahead
and ship it imagine all the sales emails
dude so isn't that crazy so like so
that's why these guys are taken off
because they basically say you know
where you had employees you no longer
need employees or if you had a good
employee they're now they can they can
now be 10 times more productive uh when
they do this you know so so this is like
kind of mind-blowing on the like text
generation for business side of things
this is crazy let me tell you like
absolutely another wild example are you
going to use this for your business yeah
so yeah exactly so I'm using it I just
started using this for for ours
well two things one is I'm gonna try to
use it when we do our prior writing
course I'm going to teach people how to
use this but also use it in the like
kind of the sales process but um like
with our Ecom thing I want to try it uh
even with milk Road like there's like
there's cases where maybe our writers
can be more productive if we give them
this tool for example every day at the
milk road we met we start with an opener
that's like yo uh hey what's up does the
milk Road the crypto newsletter that
brings you new so fresh you'll think
it's you know
um new so fresh it'll smell like laundry
straight out of the dryer I love that
smell and it's like that's what we like
I just made that up off top my head but
you give it three of those and then we
could just tell Jasper generate and
it'll generate like 500 clever openers
like that which is great because that's
like one thing our writers every day
have to come up with a cool new one and
like you know it takes like you know a
little mental energy to do that and it's
it's not the easiest thing but now they
can get better doing things like that
let me give you a wild example so go to
uh I don't know where this is gonna be I
don't know if they have a website how
are they any different than copy AI
because that I invested in copier and
they do they're kind of the same thing
just imagine with more Revenue
[Laughter]
all right those guys are cool
it's kind of like LeBron James just not
good
what's the difference between LeBron
just imagine B taller faster stronger
more handsome more successful and richer
I think no I I've been in that by the
way I'm an investor in Topia I love
those guys uh Paul is the founder who I
invested in they're at 10 million in
Revenue yeah it looks like there's it
looks like they're actually quite
similar but I think they're geared
towards a different user but uh yeah I
would have to dig deeper into Jasper to
truly understand but anyway go ahead so
okay so here's other examples of things
that I think are amazing so this Same by
the way the same thing the way this just
helped a Content marketer or a
salesperson generate text for their
emails and blog posts like this thing
will write whole blog posts for you and
by the way you can write a blog post and
then you click the SEO button and it'll
score how SEO friendly this is and how
much it thinks it's going to drive for
you right so that's pretty smart to like
link these things together because on
the surface what the what are all these
companies doing they're just using
basically the same
sort of like gpt3 engine so on one hand
these companies are not very defensible
because anybody could take these open
source language models and build a user
interface on top of it and so like I can
create another competitor to copy AI or
Jasper or one of these kind of things
but it's all in the like the user
interface the applications and how much
like business utility you add to it so
let me give you another example of
business utility so
this is now in the photography uh use
case so for example for my eCommerce
brand we spend a lot of money every
month maybe something like five to ten
thousand dollars a month easily on
photography so you have to take pictures
of your products you have to take model
photos so you have to do castings and
then book models then they come to your
studio and then they use your products
or whatever and you take photos or
videos of that you use that for your
website you use that for your ads that
sort of thing and so that whole process
takes like multiple people right you got
a photographer you might have a casting
person you have an editor maybe
um it takes time so like we can't just
have it instantaneously like you have to
schedule these things they take weeks
um they don't always turn out good like
maybe you have uh somebody doesn't that
it didn't turn out you know the shot
didn't turn out how you wanted it
whatever so check out um dream Booth so
dream Booth let me give you the link for
this
so there's two here osmosis Ai and dream
Booth but try
um
let me give you this link so this guy
GitHub one
no this one I think work this guy I
think works at Shopify I'm correct yeah
so this guy like works in the like
future division at Shopify I believe
um strange native is his uh his Twitter
handle and so basically what he does is
he shows like
um AI can unlock unlimited product
photography so basically you could take
a generic image so like the left image
here is just oh my God a shoe on grass
that's not a particularly good it's like
kind of a glare it's on grass it looks
like he didn't put a lot of effort you
know you just went out in your backyard
or a soccer field and took this picture
and then you could just say make this
shoe look epic and then it puts it takes
that shoe cuts out the background puts
it and it automatically puts it on this
like lightning background or whatever
but like look at the other examples so
like that second example I think is
better look at the training image so
it's a dude taking a selfie in this
hoodie and it looks okay actually it
doesn't look okay it looks bad you can't
use this on your website for e-commerce
and then it generates a model like
Studio looking photo of this same hoodie
this one is kind of unbelievable to me
this is stack good where it's like dude
if I could just take me wearing some
crappy me wearing my product and like
don't care about the lighting don't care
about the background don't care if I
have my hair done that day and it'll
just generate like it gave this dude
pecs and it gave him like you know
better shoulders and like a jawline and
like you know it fixed the lighting and
it put him on a background image and
like what the hell is it but give him
how do I use this how do I use this
you just click like on the tweet for now
I don't think you can use this yet I
think this is like proof of concept I
don't think this one's like a a product
product yet uh I could be wrong but I
think a lot of these are like they're
doing demos training models just to see
what happens
um dude this is this is crazy some of
them they open source the codes right
here's this photo of this chair oh wow
put this chair in like this epic thing
so there's this and then there's someone
doing so this woman doing this thing
called osmosis which I think is more of
a real product uh let me give you the
the link to this Mickey Friedman is her
name
um so what she's doing is basically you
give it like an image and then you say
turn this into an ad and it'll turn it
into Facebook ad creative for you by
turning it into a video making it look
cooler uh that sort of thing now again I
haven't tested these products for like
for real for real to see if it's like
any good or not but the concepts are
good and whether these exact products
are the ones that do it someone's gonna
do it because all these are really
valuable business use cases that like if
I could do this now all process that's
costing me 10 grand a month
um cost me just cost 29 a month yeah
29.99 a month and it's instantaneous and
it's better now you're 10 times faster
10 times cheaper and 10 times better and
like that's the makings of like those
are billion dollar companies when they
do that and so um that's really exciting
this is just this is just 100 frame
breaking is what it is when I see this
stuff it's just like I just got a little
peek into the future
and by the way this is still super early
it these products work but so few there
are there's a lot of people hundreds of
thousands and millions of people who
know and care about this but
comparatively to how much of an impact
this is going to have this we're we're
no one knows about it
um yeah so so check this guy out so I
just talked to these guys yesterday
young guys I want to invest in them but
I didn't love their idea
um so check out this guy
I'm gonna send you a link
so I'm gonna send you this link but in
the meantime
um
you should uh
just yeah hear about so these guys
basically they're young guys they
started one guy started a company out of
college raised a little money didn't end
up working out failed and he's like then
I was just thinking about what to do
next I was kind of joining these
different communities and he's like
um then I met Hugh uh through Tick Tock
I was like how'd you guys meet I always
ask every co-founder pair how'd you guys
meet that goes we met through Tick Tock
I was like people kids meet their Tick
Tock nowadays you do YouTube what
um so he's like yeah uh Hugh has been
making Jarvis so I don't know if you've
seen the movie Iron Man but basically in
Iron Man I I guess I haven't seen it so
but it's like you know there's a AI
assistant who he like talks to and like
takes care of [__] so this guy for the
last year has been building it public on
Tick Tock trying to create Jarvis like
trying to create the real life Jarvis on
on Tick Tock he's got like a million
followers on Tick Tock as he's been
building this so they met through this
process and they decided to like create
an AI company together that actually
like does you know some version of this
and one of the things that they made the
first thing that they made is this thing
called Carter and what they're doing
with Carter is they're like you know in
games you'd walk around there's just
like you know you walk into the store
it's Grand Theft Auto there's like a guy
working at the store and they call these
NPCs non-playable characters it's just
like a character that's in the game
so that the game's not empty but they
don't do much you can just like punch
them or like talk to them they say the
same three words so what these guys
started off doing was saying hey any
game developer who wants their
characters in game to actually just be
able to talk using like AI
just plug this like line of code in and
all of your non-playable characters will
all of a sudden be like able to hold
conversations with the players uh chit
chat back and forth uh do all the stuff
we've been showing that like you know
the AI Joe Rogan AI Steve Jobs thing
like just like hold a full conversation
as long as you want or guide the player
to go do something like hey um I'm
looking for the sword they're like well
if this if it's the sword you seek you
should go and check behind the waterfall
yeah maybe there's some answers there
for you and like it guides you
automatically you don't have to hard
code that response because if the player
asks for something else they'll say
something else but like kind of guide
them towards that answer
um I don't know if it all works yet it's
like in beta whatever and I don't
honestly I don't love this use case but
it is a cool use case it's a cool idea
of like oh yeah I guess in the future
games
just these like stock characters that
are walking around are gonna not just be
like random objects they're gonna
actually be like things you can interact
with which will change the way that the
games work like you'll be able to escape
this guy hours and hours in the games
this guy Hugh just retweeted a tweet
from this guy named Alex Wang who's the
CEO of scale AI which I don't even know
what entirely scale AI is other than
it's like a 10 billion dollar software
company and so he's it's like for
labeling data it's like to to make your
to make your machine learning smarter
you need to label data let's say you're
a self-driving car company you need to
like look at a million images and point
out which what was a a Shadow versus a
dog crossing the street so they
basically give you software that will
let you upload your images and then
there's humans like I don't know the
Philippines or somewhere I think that
like will label your data for you and
you just pay per image like two cents or
what's that one cent or whatever so
presumably he's quite intelligent and he
has like a really Grand perspective
because this company is so big and he
sees lots of information he this guy
Hugh retweeted something from Alex and
he says we're at a critical turning
point for Humanity children born today
are likely to have more AI friends than
human friends AI friends are going to be
more reliable cons I don't even know
what that word conciliatory what's that
mean agreeable uh and considerate what
does this mean well what what does this
mean for childhood development and
social norms we will find out uh that's
wild I completely agree with him and
then he says loneliness is an epidemic
it's on the rise in a real public health
problem this technology what it exists
has a lot of potential for good
yeah I love that and I'm like this is so
fascinating so let me tell you three
ideas that I think somebody could build
that are not in the demos we just talked
about all right okay
idea one is exactly what he's talking
about and I call it you know
some version of either the AI friend or
the AI therapist
so there are a lot of people out there
that would benefit from therapy and
there are apps that will connect you
with a therapist on your phone like I
don't know seven cups of tea or like I
don't know
talk space I don't know some companies
you're like you're like I don't know I'm
not one of those therapy losers
[__] you broken people you know what you
use
so these companies these companies are
doing well they're they make you know uh
like 100 million dollar plus a year it's
great but it's very expensive and so if
you're working at least it's a cute
little company you know they're they're
whatever like you need like uh you know
what the crypto Bros like you you you
started using the word web 3.0 and
you're like those those Web 2.0 dorks
like that's what you have to describe
like whatever is just like human uh you
know old school yeah exactly reality
reality 2.0 AI replaces DNA that's what
I that's what I believe and so what they
were doing was they're connecting you
with the real life therapist who's
licensed and blah blah blah and blah
blah and because of that you know they
maybe take an in-person visit which
might be 150 or 200 and they turn it to
a
60 or 90 a month subscription where you
get three visits or something like that
I don't know the exact economics but
something like that where you're paying
a kind of meaningful amount of money but
you're getting it more conveniently than
if you just went to you were going in
person and you also don't have the you
know the stigma the taboo of telling
your friends where you're going I'm
going to this no they're just on your
phone in your pocket well there are I
don't know tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions of people who would
benefit from having someone to talk to
either a therapist or just a friend a
companion somebody that they can confide
in somebody that won't judge them
somebody that won't be positive and
helpful somebody that will maybe offer
good advice
um somebody that will never share their
secrets and somebody that has you don't
you know no self-interest in the matter
um
you could now provide that for like
I don't know a dollar or something like
that right like the cost and the uh the
accessibility of of curing you know sort
of like loneliness or
um helping people talk through what's on
their mind and get things off their
chest that's gonna drop dramatically so
AI therapy slash AI companion and friend
I think is a mega mega idea I think that
is a
tens of billions of dollars worth idea
now I think maybe there's going to be a
lot of competition there's not clear
like the network effects around that but
I do think that that is a a very very
big idea and I think it's very impactful
so that's one startup idea you want to
react to that and I'll give you the next
one
yeah that's pretty plain and obvious to
me like like that's a pretty obvious
straightforward Solution that's
obviously challenging to pull off but
like straightforward and we can all
predict that so yes I agree
the next one is a little sexier this is
called AI Spotify so what's AI Spotify
okay so traditionally
the music business has been like um
uh what's a situation where people just
like run into like a burning building
people just make terrible decisions it's
like a horror movie when you're like
don't go in there and they're like but I
heard a sound I want to just go check it
out you know like it's like ah you're
gonna get slaughtered that's basically
what the music business was
you know basically you're competing it's
like everybody loves music so you are
competing with a bunch of people who
want to like you know make it it's like
someone creating like a to-do list app
or something yeah do you like paint
because you're gonna get pain yeah
exactly oh you like music I guess you
like pain too because that's what you're
gonna get music and pain
um so the second thing so you know
unlikely you would even ever break out
of the like thousands of people trying
this if you did guess what here's your
prize a lawsuit your suit out of
existence whether you're a Napster or
like one of the many many music
companies that came in between okay you
survived the lawsuit your Pandora your
Spotify you you didn't even get sued out
of existence congratulations here's
shitty economics because guess what to
deliver music you have to have the
rights of the record labels they could
always they own the pricing power and uh
that's why you know Spotify after you
know like building the Best in Class
product getting everybody to use it
after 15 years or whatever like does not
have impressive economics it doesn't
does not spit off a bunch of cash the
way Google or Facebook or other
companies are able to
okay so why is AI Spotify different now
basically you can
create a really cool music app that
doesn't have to pay musicians a dollar
all right musicians everywhere are
getting pissed but you know here's
here's the good news you know uh here's
what the service would look like
the same way interior AI was just like
you want to Industrial look you want a
minimal look you know give me a starting
image and I'll riff off that what you're
going to be able to do with AI Spotify
is you pick like you can basically
upload a playlist or you could just like
um you know like pick a song that you
really like like Pandora yeah it's just
gonna be it's just gonna be Pandora
radio but they don't exist but these
these songs don't exist so it's just
gonna generate a new song on the Fly for
you and like tick tock's algorithm it's
going to learn like when you skip okay
that was not good where did they skip
why did they skip what songs get liked
um if you like this song will you like
this song that sort of thing so it's
going to generate an algorithm the
algorithm is going to generate music on
the Fly for you and then you can add
crypto to it where I would be able to
say if I hear a good song like by
default all the songs are like they're
here today gone tomorrow they're like
ephemeral you don't get to hang on to
them
but if you like the song you're like oh
I want to keep this song I want to you
you don't just get to keep it and save
it you get to own it so you'll click
mint you'll mint an nft that now you own
that song why because it was your tastes
it was your directing the engine crazy
that created that song now you own that
and maybe it could split royalties with
all the artists that like inspired that
music or the algorithm just owns you
know 50 and the user owns 50 did you
just come up with that or is someone
working on this
off the Dome baby got that big brain got
that big boy brain no small boy stuff
just straight Big Boy ideas
this is wonderful I think I yeah this is
finally when you web three nerds are
probably finally coming up with
interesting [__] a used case
[Laughter]
absolutely make no sense
seriously
with some elements of Truth
the uh but but I do think this idea is
really great I think that the I think I
think somebody should make this and it's
it's not ready yet so for example what
happened was with gpt3 somebody you know
open AI basically like downloaded all
the text of the internet to create this
text generation engine
and then with Dali they did the same
thing they downloaded all the images of
the internet to create this image
generation engine
and what these guys from the podcast
thing or the speech stuff they're
downloading all of Joe Rogan's back
catalog to generate Joe Rogan's voice as
a voice engine somebody's about to do
that for music they're about to download
all the music they're about to go
download all the music off Spotify
and then they're gonna train an engine
to say hey create new music this is what
music is
create new music and that's what's going
to happen and they're going to release
an open source model that will say would
you like to generate music Here's an API
that will just let you generate music
using this this engine that we've we've
been training by downloading all the
music that exists
wow brilliant finally finally
[Laughter]
ever dude you did it
you peaked the back
but that is brilliant finally
too good
we're so stupid it's like Beavis and
Butthead made a few bucks
yeah you might have artificial
intelligence but we got that real
stupidity over here
this is so stupid all right what's the
third one
um I don't know I lost my list I just
clicked but um okay the last thing I
want to leave everybody with is
um there's this guy who's I think the I
think he should be the Billy of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
a million dollars isn't cool you know
what's cool a billion dollars
so emad is his name he's the guy who is
behind stable diffusion so do you know
what stable diffusion is
no I know that the tweet that you just
referenced was talking all about stable
diffusion so stable diffusion was
basically
um an open source competitor to Dali so
open AI created Dali it took over
everybody was excited about it but you
know you had like you had to get
permission to even use it we were asking
hey who can get us permission for gpt3
we want to get access who can get us
access to Dolly oh you have to pay for
all these credits oh you don't know XYZ
so stable diffusion is basically a um
their tagline's great AI by the people
for the people designing Implement
designing and implementing Solutions
using collective intelligence and
augmented technology they're just
they're like the FUBU of the AI world
you know what I'm saying
yeah anybody who died
generally they're full of [__] but this
guy uh I watch one interview with him
and I could confidently say from the
bottom of my heart after this one
interview I watched this guy's the real
deal Holyfield so let me tell you about
this guy so he
um gives off he's he's my Billy of the
week uh he's not a billionaire yet but
this guy's gonna be a billionaire he
basically for stable diffusion he put in
600 000 I think to fund like the
development of it uh the company's worth
like a billion dollars already what was
he wealthy from so the guy he's born in
Jordan he's got like a British accent
for some reason he's like a math
background font type guy you could just
tell in like the first thing that's
talking to him it's like
I bet this guy could say more than five
prime numbers and it's like yeah yeah he
definitely can
um so he works at a hedge fund and he's
like I'm the Quant guy at this hedge
fund I'm doing trading and it's good
like I'm it felt good to try to win that
game and I was winning that game okay
good so he does that then he has this
life change he has his first kid and his
son is diagnosed with autism so he he
decides to take a few years off I don't
know because it was the autism or just
because he had a kid but he decides okay
I'm not gonna do the Hedge fun thing I
just kind of retired early after winning
the hedge fund game
um retires and he's like okay um goes to
the doctor and he's like what do I do
about this like you know what can we do
when it comes to autism and he's like
well there's no like there's no solution
and he's like
but I'm an engineer like I have a
problem that means there must be a
solution like and he's like no there's
no solution he's like doesn't accept
that response
so he starts doing his own research and
basically ends up like I don't know
curing his son's autism or at least
making it a lot a lot better so here's
how he did it he basically was like all
right there's a lot of like literature
out there like research papers but if I
try to read this one by one it's going
to take me forever so he creates a ninja
that just ingests all the papers and
does a semantic search on it and
basically creates like this machine
learning thing to learn what is all the
research about about autism telling us
and uh and by the way
I didn't verify any of this I don't know
if any of this was real this sounds a
little too good to be true but again
just judging the book by its cover I
think these guys watch it so I choose to
believe this is the biggest hedge ever
it takes like three weeks from now this
guy turns out to like you know this guy
pivots to selling his nft collection and
it's like oh wait this guy changed his
name and like used to launder money for
a living in case that comes out let me
just say there's a chance
probably probably he's just a super nerd
who's amazing okay let me tell you why I
think that's true just because he's a
brown guy with a British accent is what
you're saying you said just based off of
what he looks like and the vocabulary is
stunning so he's describing autism and
he's like you know the way that he's
like autism is a is a sort of like uh
it's a it's a phenotype it's like a um
it's like a a behavioral description and
it has underlying causes which is like a
certain chemist body chemistry things
he's like well what causes those and
could we rebalance the body chemistry so
that the behavior changes and what he
realized was that autism as a whole
comes from many different types of these
imbalances and he's like so he's like
their doctors are correct that we can't
just like fix it or cure it because
there's so it's a multimodal system
there's so many different
um like inputs that create this output
he's like but on an individual level if
you can understand where in one
individual to buy body chemistry is
maybe slightly different perhaps there
is a treatment that we could do or there
is a rebalancing that you can do of the
body's biochemistry and so he starts to
create like a uh
a process for himself over a couple
years to try to help this and he said in
this interview I was watching he's like
yes you know his my son is doing so much
better and like you know uh like he
didn't claim like oh I've cured autism
or anything like that but he's like I
learned you know deeply like you know
what was what goes into these kind of
like biological
systems and like uh what we can do you
know how maybe science is going to get
better in the future using AI so that's
kind of where his AI itch got got
started you know machine learning and AI
is going to be able to help these things
and so um then in 2020 he's at a dinner
in Davos
um you know as yeah as yeah as one does
yeah as British people with British
accents huge vocabularies do I have
dinner at Chick-fil-A last night okay
this guy was at a dinner in Davos and uh
he's uh he's he's there you know and
he's uh people are talking about this
virus coming out of China and he's like
huh that's the way they're describing
this virus uh is covid-19 thing he looks
into it he's like it sounds very similar
to autism where it's a he calls it a
multi
multi-stomic inflammatory disease and
it's basically his main thing was like
this thing is complicated and he's like
it was pretty clear right away that uh
developing a vaccine for this was going
to take some time like we weren't going
to be able to do this in months it was
probably going to take you know a year
year or more uh to try to figure this
out
and uh and even if we did it wouldn't
work for everybody because again this is
like a multimodal system and like you
know these like one size fits all
solutions are not I'm not going to work
very well and so he starts this like
thing to try to help
um use data to help you know policy
makers for covid like do a better job
blah blah blah
um anyway he goes through this process
the bureaucracy of like this whole like
you know dealing with these World health
organizations and UNESCO and World Bank
and all the stuff you know it ends up
being too bureaucratic and he like you
know gets fed up with it and it just
like sort of the whole initiative
collapses and then he comes up with what
he calls his Promethean Mission uh the
Prometheus the myth of the guy who you
know sort of like gives fire to him it's
like I want to open source all of the
powerful Ai and ml tools that exist so
that they're not controlled by large
private corporations
I like that
um and so that's why the the for us bias
baby like open AI is called open AI but
it's a private organization they're very
you know close to the vest about what
they're working on and then when they
release it they release it kind of like
not to everybody all at once and all
that stuff and if you look at the charts
like stable diffusion has like far
surpassed open Ai and the the the tweet
that went viral on this was like you
know open AI meaning the actual open
sourced AI is beating open AI right so
the the people who actually are taking
an open approach are crushing now the
company the private organization how do
they make money then
um I think it's the same sort of thing
you like you know you pay for some
credits or usage along the way like they
open source the model
but if you want to run it blah blah and
who knows maybe they're going to have
some like you know open source companies
have these like weird weird models where
it's like Linux you know Red Hat makes a
bunch of money through services and
things like that that are not like what
you would expect
um so you know he says he starts stable
diffusion because his daughter asked him
if he could do the same thing he did for
you know covet or whatever for art oh by
the way in between he wins this grant
that uh or this like X prize like I
think um
uh Elon Musk and somebody else put up
this 15 million dollar prize for who can
uh what was it so
um it was like who can basically create
a system that
um like teaches kids in foreign
countries like I don't know I forgot
what it was like English or mathematics
uh for less than like you know 75
dollars a total cost just like that and
basically they had created this thing on
an iPad that you could just give to kids
in like countries that they would
basically like be able to learn or pass
certain tests within 75 days or
something like that I don't know the
exact specifics but he wins this great
he wins this like 15 million dollar uh
thing again doing good in the world and
so um so anyways he creates stable
diffusion and um
or his company stability AI creates
releases stable diffusion it kind of
takes off
um and he also has you know what that
think uh what's it called like
a Fantasia
where it's like you say a word and it
creates an image in your head or
something like that or like uh or like
emotions have colors or something like
that it's like yeah it's like these
senses are linked in your brain in a way
that's not normal but like numbers have
smells you know other [__] like that uh
he has one of those
what has it been
synesthesia there's synesthesia but he
has a different one uh he has another
one I think called a Fantasia
um anyway so he's like supporting
researchers and he's trying to give the
money to like open source this thing and
then he's like okay I'm gonna bring
together 20 of the best Engineers like
Manhattan Project Style and I'm gonna
self-fund this thing and I'm going to
like uh you know we're going to create
you know a project in this space and
they create a stable diffusion and
basically uh you know he he's
self-funded 600 000 and got these 20
Engineers to come in and they created
this thing that's like you know taken
off and now you know valued over a
billion dollars dude isn't it crazy just
how old some people are just like it
just
when I talked to Ryan holiday the other
day for the Pod I felt inspired at the
end because I was like
your type of success
is awesome and inspiring to me because I
I too can work hard and like achieve
what you achieve and then I hear a story
like this guy and I'm like he just like
that story just [__] slapped me in the
face you know what I mean like like like
I just I am I am nothing and I am nobody
and this guy is gonna steal my lunch
money that's what this that idea just
bullied me no he's not gonna steal your
lunch buddy he's gonna to give you lunch
money and you're like who are why did
you give why are you giving me lunch
money and he's just like don't even
worry about it son and you're like wow
thanks Dad yeah like this guy he just
straight stored at this yeah
I feel inadequate yeah that's actually
what the middle of the week section is
it's really the it inadequacy of the
week yeah it's like ladies and gentlemen
are you ready to feel like [__]
I got a story for you this guy
richer than you did it faster than you
doing the same thing you said you wanted
to do but he actually did it and guess
what he's also ripped
that's what I feel about Ahmad uh do you
is there a world where he's full of [__]
like I said I didn't know of this guy's
existence to like three weeks ago so
yeah like you know there's there's
definitely a world where everything I
just said turns out to be like you know
not true or this guy turns out to be a
you know he's like yeah I taught those
kids math but then you know they work
for me now and it's like whoa whoa
what's going on here
why are the kids again working for you
bro
there's like this commercial uh for a
car commercial and it there there's like
uh they're on the highway and it's in uh
bumper to bumper traffic and this guy
pulls off on the side of the road and
starts going through this bumpy force
and uh the the guy in the passenger seat
goes dude this is pretty scary have you
ever taken this shortcut before and the
guy driving goes yeah once including
this time that's like uh uh you telling
these stories you're just like yeah yeah
yeah I know all about this guy I just
learned about him an hour ago
yeah I'm literally reading it while I'm
talking
I'm reading my researchers notes while
we're talking uh because I watched the
interview but I wasn't taking notes
because I was driving at the time and so
all I remember is my feeling right
what's the Maya Angelou quote
you won't remember the facts of what
you're researching you'll just remember
how it made you feel that's what
happened to me uh yeah I don't remember
any of the words this guy said and I
didn't go fact check them but I remember
Angela said that yeah they were famous
quotes like people won't remember what
you say they'll remember how you made
them feel uh so it's basically that I
remember how this guy made me feel and
he made me feel the same way I felt when
I heard vitalik talk for the first time
we get the knees
you know vitalik when I heard him talk
Zuckerberg when you hear them talk like
people who are extremely Mission driven
while also being slightly Asperger's and
also being extremely impressive in their
past accomplishments and they're just
very matter-of-fact about the way they
think the world is going and they're not
trying to Hype you up they're not trying
to sell you on it
so you asked them a question they gave
you their answer and then you're like
that answer just broke your frame and so
you keep asking them questions and then
and there it's almost like the tone of
their voice is sort of like I said what
I said I you know like yes this is what
I believe and this is what I'm doing
with my time and yes like no yeah this
is what I think is important and you're
just like you know you just sort of like
you look stupid when you're talking to
them because you just come from like you
know it's like you're speaking a
different language uh you know they're
speaking a language of like being
Mission driven and confident and like
knowing their [__] and you're just like
you know me you know just being silly
old me trying to understand what the
hell they're talking about dude this is
one of those episodes that we record and
I it's like I have to take a nap at the
end I'm so exhausted from excitement do
you ever get like that you're like a you
know like my dog like if I like feed him
too many treats like in such a way where
he like gets pumped up and Hyper about
it he's got to take a nap just from the
excitement that's how I feel like I
gotta go like rest my eyes like I'm
gonna go like I'm gonna go buy a dad
chair just to take this nap that I need
I need to be reclined at it 34 degree
angle and my feet
yeah yeah at the end of this episode I'm
gonna get up and make a grunting noise
just because just because
not from
yeah just out of habit
this is uh just so fascinating to me I
think this episode has had a lot of
mind-blowing things I'm eager to see
what people say I think that I feel just
amped after I this is almost like a quit
and dedicate your life to this topic
type of thing you're like um almost
not actually good it's like it's like
it's like people it's like with someone
who has worked at your company forever
and it's their last day you just you
gotta go say goodbye and hug them but
they're like all the way across the room
you know what I mean
like
they're like worked for you for like 10
years and you know their wife's name and
their kids names and you're so excited
to give them a hug and tell them how
much they mean to you but
it's the couch is really comfortable and
they're just all the way across they're
all the way across the it's gonna be at
least 50 steps AI is all the way across
the room that's so good all right we're
out of here
[Music]
foreign